- Morning, Quinta.
- Hey, good morning.
Well, well, well.
Look who decided to drink
too much last night.
Now you gotta hang out
with me, your hangover.
(laughs) Hi! (laughs)
Oh, look at you trying
to walk to your desk,
but you can't 'cause I'm draining
every single bit of
energy you thought you had
when you woke up this morning, you idiot.
- Hey, Quinta.
- Woah, woah!
We got a yeller, we
got a yeller, everyone.
Just kidding.
I'm giving you a headache
that makes you think everyone
around you is Gilbert Gottfried.
(laughs)
You did this to yourself, you know.
I wasn't even supposed to be here.
There was a kid with finals today
I was gonna bother,
but you asked for this,
so here I am.
It all looks like hieroglyphics
to you, doesn't it?
Why don't you try to
take a walk, you know.
Maybe walk this one off.
See if that works.
You feel better?
That's cute.
That's nice.
That's a sweet miracle.
Seems too good to be true, doesn't it?
That's because it is!
Vomit ray!
Run to the bathroom!
(laughs evilly)
OK, you're clammy, you're clammy.
You're really, really clammy.
(laughs) Look at you,
you're sweating like Donald
Trump at a taco stand.
I'm having a ball here, people.
I'm having a good time.
OK, you've suffered enough.
Guess I'll go now.
So I'll catch you next time
you forget you're an adult
with responsibilities?
Don't worry about it, alright.
We'll just make it an impromptu
date out of it, alright.
Bye!
I love you.
Oh, and by the way, you
have a wedding next weekend.
Just let me know if
you want me to show up,
the day after, of course.